captured on mobile phone the aftermath
of a suicide attack al-qaeda fighters
detonated a car bomb in one of mali's
biggest military camp in sivari inside
are the barracks of hundreds of russian
fighters they repelled the assault but
lost a russian helicopter
al-qaeda says this was a retaliation
against recent operations by mali's
military involving russian fighters in
the center of the country
malian state tv follows the authorities
on the ground here in the village of
mura an operation to win hearts and
minds in what human rights group believe
is the sight of a massacre
they say russian mercenaries and malian
soldiers tortured and killed almost a
thousand people mostly civilians in the
last month in the village of mura and
humbori
these soldiers that you see in the
village are only your brothers children
and grandchildren
they can never be your enemy nor the
enemy of mora
mountain authorities are blocking the
u.n from meeting the survivors and
conducting an independent investigation
al jazeera spoke to one of the survivors
mamadou not his real name says he was on
his way to a market when he heard the
helicopters of the malian army hover
overhead out came what mamadou describes
as white-skinned soldiers shooting
indiscriminately
soldiers over there accompanied by white
soldiers there are many of them i can't
recognise the patches on their uniforms
i'm afraid to approach them but people
say they're russians many people have
died because of their violence
malian authorities deny the presence of
russian fighters instead calling them
instructors in a statement al qaeda said
it is holding hostage captured russian
fighters linked to the wagner group
with the deployment of russian fighters
last december the relationship between
malian authorities and france has
deteriorated the near 2500 french
soldiers are pulling out of malibu this
summer
last week french forces handed over the
camp of gositamalian forces
the malian army says it found a mass
grave shortly after that contained
bodies in advanced state of
decomposition but the french military
has released drone and audio footage
showing malian soldiers digging dead
bodies into the sand after they had left
a senior french military official told
al jazeera that russians are behind a
campaign of disinformation targeting the
french army
in mali away from europe is a new
battlefront in an information war
involving the russians and the west
and caught in the middle
are the people of mali
nicholas hawk al jazeera